Dear God, thank You for this time together to consider Your Word to us.
I pray that we'll have open minds and open hearts to hear Your message to us.
I pray that I will get out of the way so that Your message will shine in our minds
and hearts.
In the name of the Father and Son and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
All right, this weekend working around in the yard, I hurt my back.
So I have this chair just in case, thanks Brandon.
But if I grimace or fall, it's not part of the lesson.
So just to let you know.
Also I had to take a little white pill this morning.
So if I say something really weird, please don't hold it against me.
I won't remember it anyway, so that's okay.
If you're visiting with us, welcome.
Thank you for being here.
We are going through a series called Firm Foundation where we're going through the
nine core beliefs of our church.
When Brandon asked me earlier this week if I would fill in, I was happy to do it.
He reminded me that we would be on the core belief of Jesus, which I thought, hey, you
know, I mean, there's certainly plenty of material there.
But I've really struggled with this lesson because it's like, I think I was telling
Brandon before the service, I'd rather teach you on one verse than on something
that's the whole Bible.
Because I've had a hard time getting exactly where I wanted to be with this.
But so hopefully you'll be as blessed as I have been by this lesson.
Let's start with a story from a long time ago from my life.
Jenny and I both.
We, Jenny and I went to Mississippi State for college and we met our freshman years,
there's a whole story there, but I won't bore you with.
We met our freshman year in a campus ministry that we attended.
Of course, this was the first time we were living away from home.
And we were very committed to our walk as Jesus followers.
And we were committed to sharing our faith with students on campus.
I think it was our sophomore year that we had a good friend in our ministry
who was dating a guy who was not a Christian.
And she had conversations with him, but eventually she wanted someone else to
talk to him about following Jesus.
And I was glad to do it.
I was comfortable sharing my faith.
And I had struck up already struck up a friendship with this with this guy.
And so we agreed to meet even though this was about 50 years ago.
I remember this occasion very clearly.
We met on a stage in the church auditorium.
Nobody else was there.
And I was confident I was prepared for this conversation.
And when we started the conversation, he started with a request.
He said, so tell me about this guy, Jesus.
Well, I was not prepared for that request.
I was well prepared for the question, how do I become a Christian?
I knew exactly what to say about that.
And I was prepared, but I was not prepared to talk about who Jesus is.
I remember the occasion clearly.
I remember the room where we sat and his question.
But you know, I don't remember my answer at all.
I think my pride has blocked it out.
What I do remember is there was a lot of hymning and hawing, a lot of us and well.
Fortunately, his faith journey did not depend on my preparation or my competence
and sharing my faith.
And he still became a Jesus follower.
But this event taught me something very important.
It taught me that the foundation of our faith includes an understanding of who Jesus is.
It seems simple.
I wish I had something like, you know, the statement here to share with him.
I could have said this.
There's certainly nothing in the statement that I didn't know at the time, couldn't talk about or didn't believe.
I believed all of it and certainly knew all of the stories.
But I was really not prepared, you know, to coherently talk about who Jesus was with somebody in a conversational way.
Of course, I was young.
As we're going through this firm foundation series where this is our fifth of the nine core beliefs that we have.
But I think there's a tendency as we think through these nine core beliefs, there's a tendency to see them as kind of disconnected pieces.
But I hope that it doesn't escape your attention the interconnectedness and sequencing of these core beliefs.
So far we've covered God.
We've covered the scriptures, which is God's word, humanity, sin and now Jesus.
But consider the following just as kind of a thought experiment here.
Consider the following as a summary of these core beliefs.
And as I say this, I want you to see the five that we've covered so far as we as as they sequence through this.
In the beginning God, the creator and sustainer of all things created all we see and don't see through the power of his word.
In the ultimate act of his love, he created humans in his image.
Although humans were offered eternal life with God, they chose instead to rebel, which resulted in sin and death entering the world.
The sin problem could not be solved by humans and could only be solved by God himself.
To that end and in his love and mercy, the father sent Jesus to die on the cross and then by the power of his word raised him from the dead.
So did you hear the sequence? God, his word, the scriptures, humanity, sin and now we talk about Jesus.
So we have nine core beliefs and we covered four of them.
So now we come to the fifth core belief, which is right in the middle of the nine.
So as Westerners, we when we list things, we tend to list the most important either first or last.
And that's pretty typical in our culture.
But if you pay close attention to the Bible, Hebrew writers, both old and New Testament, tend to put the preeminent in the center.
So considering the following, just to make the point, the center of the Torah is Leviticus and the center of Leviticus is chapter 29, which talks about the day of atonement.
Many scholars believe the day of atonement is the center of the Torah, the center of the center.
The tabernacle was in the center of the camp of the Israelites as they were going to the Promised Land.
And the tenta meeting or what we might call the Holy of Holies was in the center of the tabernacle.
And in the center of the tenta meeting or Holy of Holies was the Ark of the Covenant, the center of the center of the center.
Unless you think that this is just an Old Testament thing, the center of the Sermon on the Mount is the Lord's Prayer.
Jesus died in the center between the two thieves on the cross.
So I don't know if this was intended, Brandon, but I'm going to give you credit.
So take all the credit that our core belief about Jesus is in the center of our nine.
And to think about it, this is the way it should be.
This is the story of the Bible from Genesis to Revelation, the story that Jesus is in the center.
So just to make this point, consider Colossians 1.
If you have your Bible, you can turn to Colossians 1 starting in verse 15.
It says, and as I'm reading this notice the number of times Paul says all things.
Starting in verse 15, he is the image of the invisible God, the firstborn of all creation.
For by him all things were created in heaven and earth, visible and invisible,
whether thrones or dominions or rulers or authorities, all things were created through him and for him.
And he is before all things and in him all things hold together.
And he is the head of the body, the church.
He is the beginning, the firstborn of the dead, that in everything he might be preeminent.
And in him all the fullness of God is pleased to dwell and through him to reconcile to himself all things,
whether on earth or heaven, making peace by the blood of his cross.
It is only fitting that Jesus is the center of our nine core beliefs because he is in the center of all things.
So we have this statement of core belief in Jesus, but it's important for us to have certainty in that statement.
Because we're committing our lives to this, we need to have certainty.
The New Testament writers wrote about this certainty in the early years of the church.
There were many people including the apostles who saw Jesus teach, walk the earth, perform miracles.
And in 1 Corinthians 15 it says there were more than 500 people who saw Jesus after he rose from the dead.
Most of those were early disciples, were members in first century churches and they would travel around to these churches as eye witnesses talking about what they saw.
But as the years went on many of these eye witnesses died and there were more and more Christians that had not seen Jesus
and more and more churches that didn't have any of these 500 eye witnesses to give testimony.
So when Peter wrote his letter 35 years or so after Jesus died, he was aware that his readers needed certainty.
And frankly this is important for us, 2,000 years later.
So listen to what Peter says in 2 Peter 1 starting in verse 16.
For we did not follow cleverly devised myths when we made known to you the power and coming of our Lord Jesus Christ.
But we were eye witnesses of His majesty.
For when we received honor and glory from God the Father and the voice was born to Him by the majestic glory.
This is my beloved son whom I am well pleased.
We ourselves heard this very voice born from heaven for we were with Him on the holy mountain.
And we have the prophetic word more fully confirmed to which you will do well to pay attention as a lamp shining in a dark place until the day dawns and the morning store rises in your hearts.
Knowing this first of all that no prophecy of scripture comes from someone's own interpretation for no prophecy was ever produced by the will of man.
But men spoke from God as they were carried along by the Holy Spirit.
So I have known some atheists in my day and when it comes to Jesus they might agree that there was a man named Jesus who walked on this earth.
They might believe the stories about him were interesting and maybe even compelling.
But they would not believe that the claims that Jesus made were true.
But Peter says that we don't follow cleverly devised myths.
When I talk to atheists that's a lot of times similar kinds of words that they would use.
It's all kind of made up by his followers after the fact.
Peter said I was there at his baptism and I was there at his transfiguration.
I heard the voice say this is my son whom I love.
But he makes another argument that connects to one of our other core beliefs.
He says that we have certainty in Jesus because of the scriptures both Old and New Testament that are written by men.
Not by their own interpretation that they are inspired.
We also have 1 Peter chapter 1 verse 8 and 9 where Peter talks about this topic as well and relate to us.
He says though you have not seen him you love him.
And though you do not now see him you believe in him and rejoice with joy that is inexpressible and filled with glory.
Obtaining the outcome of your faith the salvation of your souls.
There is a good lead on to next week when we talk about salvation.
Peter's audience is like us. They have never seen Jesus in person.
But Peter says we can have certainty in the story of Jesus.
And after these verses he says the prophecies about Jesus are for us to give us certainty about Jesus.
And therefore we can love him. We can believe in him. We can have faith in him.
Now let's take a few moments to look at John's prophetic poem in John chapter 1.
You can find it in your worship guide as well.
But let's take a second to read that and then we'll talk a few minutes about it.
John 1.1.
He was not the light but he came to bear witness about the light.
The true light which gives light to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
Yet the world did not know him.
He came to his own and his own people did not receive him.
But to all who did receive him who believed in his name he gave the right to become children of God.
Who were born not of blood nor of the will of the flesh nor of the will of man but of God.
And the word became flesh and dwelt among us and we have seen his glory.
Glory is the only son from the Father full of grace and truth.
John bore witness about him and cried out this is he whom I said he who comes after me ranks before me and because he was before me.
For from his fullness we have all received grace upon grace.
For the law was given through Moses grace and truth came through Jesus Christ.
No one has ever seen God the only God who is at the Father's side.
He has made him known.
Now before we look at the content or we'll pull out some things from the content of this poem.
Let's notice something about the structure.
So this is a highly structured poem.
There are two sections the first section verses one through 13.
And in this section John is poetically describing Jesus incarnation but he's using the words of the creation event of Genesis one and two.
So right you see it in the beginning right.
Genesis one one and we have the word.
Then we have the light and we have the darkness.
So all of those are words that we see in the Genesis creation account.
Then the second section and starting in verse 14 goes 14 to 18.
And in this section John is poetically describing Jesus incarnation in the language of something else from the Old Testament.
And that is the tabernacle.
So this word dwell in verse 14 where it says.
Dwelled with us that word dwell means tent.
It's the same word in the Greek version of the Old Testament that was used to describe the tabernacle.
This could say he tended with us.
So there's mention of glory which is a big part of the story around the tabernacle.
There's mention of the law through Moses which of course is another part of that story.
And then no one's seeing God which is another part of the story when Moses wants to see God.
There's this mention about people not seeing God face to face.
So both sections have a mention of John the Baptist.
It's kind of weird because that's why you can see there's two sections.
The first section has a mention of John the Baptist and the second section has a mention of John the Baptist.
And then finally after two sections then we have a very interesting concluding sentence.
So look at it.
I didn't know this until I was preparing for this lesson.
It's very interesting.
The last sentence says he has made him known.
Now presumably the he is the son and the him is the father in this sentence.
But apparently they didn't know this but in Greek the sentence actually doesn't have a direct object in Greek.
When they translated the Bible into English they just added a direct object in Greek.
And then they translated the Bible into English.
When they translated the Bible into English they just added a direct object, the him,
because in the context he's talking about the father.
And so they added a direct object so that in English we read he has made him known.
But in Greek there's no him.
So if you read the sentence in Greek it's a sentence that like trails off without an end.
The sentence would read, actually it's not a sentence but it would read,
he has made known dot dot dot.
So it begs the reader to question what has he made known?
What has he made known about the father which he's just talking about?
So this poem is a prologue to the Gospel of John.
And it's a book about Jesus.
So John in the structure of this poem and then this sentence that doesn't end,
he's inviting us to read to find out what Jesus is going to make known.
He's going to make known?
Well, keep reading.
There's a lot of interesting things we could talk about.
But let's pull out a few truths from this passage as we look at it.
First of all, John is saying that if you want to fully understand who Jesus is,
you have to go all the way back to the beginning.
Now, this is not the way I grew up.
The way I grew up, I grew up significantly downplaying the role of the Old Testament
in understanding who Jesus was.
I knew there were prophecies and they were important in validating Jesus,
what he did and his status as the Messiah.
But that's about it if I've been using the Old Testament to understand about Jesus.
But John is saying something very different.
He's saying the story of Jesus starts in Genesis 1.
And the implication is then the whole Old Testament is centered on the story of Jesus as well.
So that's one.
Secondly, John is saying that Jesus was both fully God and fully human.
We see that in verse 1, the word was God.
And then in verse 14, the word became flesh.
Fully God, fully human.
Thirdly, John makes the point that Jesus is God's Son.
It's not the only place it's mentioned, but it is mentioned in this poem.
We see that in verse 14 and verse 18.
And then finally, John is expanding our view of reality.
So he does that in at least three ways.
I'll just mention three.
Expanding our normal sense of reality.
First, notice John says in the first verses that the word was with God and the word was God.
Right?
Now think about that.
How does that work?
How is something with something and it's the thing as well?
It makes no sense.
John is inviting his readers into a different sense of reality.
The word was with God and the word was God.
Secondly, we've already mentioned this.
Jesus was fully God and fully human.
So we've come to accept this truth.
It's in our core belief.
But Bible scholars have been debating what this actually means.
How does this work?
That Jesus is fully God and fully human.
Right?
We've been talking about that since the beginning of time.
It's interesting but hard to grasp.
And then finally, notice what John the Baptist says in the second section.
He says that Jesus was after him and Jesus was before him.
So again, how is something after something and before something at the same time?
So John is just blowing our minds with this poem.
And then it finishes with an incomplete sentence to encourage us to read on.
Read the story. Keep reading the story.
And when we keep reading, we see Jesus lives a sinless life.
We see him suffer at the hands of earthly authorities.
We see him be obedient to his father even unto death and the cross.
And we see him raised from the dead on the third day.
So John and the other gospel writers give us a certainty in who Jesus is.
But I'm here to tell you that it is important to have a certainty in who Jesus is.
But it is at least as important, maybe more important,
to have a certainty of who Jesus is to me.
The story of Jesus is a story of God coming to earth to invite us into a relationship with God.
It's important to believe that Jesus is King of Kings.
But it's more important that he is my King.
It's important to believe that Jesus is Lord of Lords.
But it's more important that he is my Lord.
That he is the Lord of my life.
And even though I'm thankful for the gift of adoption into God's family,
that I still view myself as a servant of God.
It's important to believe that Jesus died on the cross.
But it's more important to understand that he died on the cross for me.
And even though I'm thankful for the gift that he gave to me on the cross,
I have been crucified with Christ.
I'm no longer I who live but Christ who lives in me.
And the life I now live in the flesh, I live by faith in the Son of God who loved me and gave himself for me.
It's important to believe that Jesus was raised from the dead.
But it's more important to believe that as Jesus was raised from the dead,
that I have been raised to walk a new life and ultimately will be raised in new creation.
So this cannot be overstated. Our belief in Jesus is important.
But notice what James said.
He said, you believe that God is one?
You do well.
But even the demons believe and shudder.
Notice what John says at the end of his gospel.
Now Jesus did many other signs in the presence of the disciples which are not written in this book.
But these are written so that we may believe that Jesus is the Christ, the Son of God.
And that by believing, we can have life in his name.
As James says, believing is good, but it's God's desire and intention that we have eternal life with him.
Jesus' invitation to us is that we come to him.
Matthew 11, he says, come to me all you who labor and are heavy laid.
Now I'll give you rest, take my yoke upon you and learn from me, for I am gentle and lowly in heart
and you will find rest for your souls.
For my yoke is easy, my burden is light.
And then notice what Scripture says at the very end of the Bible in Revelation chapter 22.
Jesus talking to John says, I, Jesus, have sent my angel to testify to you about these things for the churches.
I am the root and the descendant of David and the bright morning star.
The spirit and the bride say, come and let the one who hears say, come and let the one who is thirsty come.
Let the one who desires to take the water of life without price.
We've been talking about Jesus at the center of all things.
Paul uses the word preeminent, at least in English, that's our word.
Paul says that Jesus is preeminent, but Peter uses a different metaphor.
Peter said that Jesus is the cornerstone.
But again, not to belabor the point, it's important to realize Jesus is the cornerstone.
But it's more important that Jesus is the cornerstone of my life.
It's important that all parts of my life are built on the cornerstone of Jesus.
That my marriage is built on the cornerstone of Jesus.
That my parenting is built on the cornerstone of Jesus.
That my interactions with the world are built on the cornerstone of Jesus.
And that my mission and fellowship in his church are built on the cornerstone of Jesus.
Quoting from the Old Testament, Peter said,
Behold, I'm laying in Zion a stone, a cornerstone chosen and precious,
and whoever believes in him will not be put to shame.
So our core belief is that God in the person of Jesus came down to us.
We can have certainty in this. We can have certainty.
It is true. And that in full assurance, we can have faith in Jesus as a cornerstone of our life.
With him. Let's pray.
Thank you, Father, for your mercy and care for us.
Thank you, Jesus, for coming and showing us how to live in this world.
Thank you for offering yourself in death for us.
Sanctify us by your spirit so that we will offer ourselves in faith to you.
In Jesus' name, amen.